So far, the only option we've seen for
adding custom functionalities for
our build script is via ad hoc tasks.
We've also seen how typed
tasks make it simple to
reuse common functionality
throughout our build scripts.
We'll now learn how to
write our own task types.
Creating a custom task
type in gradle is easy
Let's start by defining our task class.
Again, since Gradle
scripts are simply groovy,
we can define a class
right in our build script.
In general, we'll always extend
the default task class which provides
a basic implementation
of the task interface.
We've got class MyTask
extends DefaultTask.
That's all there is to it to
define a custom task type.
Of course, since we didn't provide any
additional capability for our task.
It's functionally the same as defining
an ad hoc task in a build script.
We have to somehow tell gradle what we
want our task to do when it executes.
Luckily gradle has also
made this very simple.
To add an action to our task
type we simply define a method
annotated with the at
task action annotation.
Let's start by adding an action
that simply prints a string out
to the console.
Now that we have defined our task
type and given it an action.
We can create an instance of this
task type in our build script
just as we would with
any other typed task.
Let's go ahead and add a task named
Hello doorbelled\g script and
declare its type as this new
hello task we've just created.
So, we've got our new hello task of
type, hellotask, let's give it a try.
There we go.
The method of the HelloTask class
that we annotated with TaskAction
got executed.
Perfect.
We can also easily make
our tasks configurable
by adding properties to our class.
Here we've added a firstName property,
which our task action then uses.
Remember, since this is Groovy, we don't
need to worry about creating getter and
setter methods.
We've declared a task HelloName
of type HelloNameTask.
And then we've configured the first
name property of our HelloNameTask.
If we give this a try, aw, hey console.
Hello to you too.